before we get into the film i like
asking a few curveballs at the beginning
some fun stuff oh good
not hard-hitting um if someone has
actually never seen anything that you've
done before what is the first thing you
want them watching and why
maybe you can go first
that is so good wait so like am i
allowed to say living or no
you can't absolutely
that would probably be lit i think it
would be living i mean i i i think like
the the obvious one would be sex
education but i actually
beca but because people really i feel
that's very
i'm just i'm very saturated in that in
my life and i love it but it is like a
lot of the time it's something that
really
it's been kind of put next to my name
and it now defines me even though i've
done lots of other things
um and i i think that living is like my
first you know it's like my first proper
film role and i think i think it's the
most beautiful film so i would say
living
i just as a add to that the very first
thing i ever saw amy do was a play
which i thought was extraordinary
she was doing uncle vania
and so my initiation into her was not
actually through the
i then also did see sex education but i
remember that but for me um
i don't know i mean
my previous film i think was such a big
identifier for me um
because it was a it was a film that i
think i sort of just yeah i just
metastasized as a director and came into
my
into my way um and so i guess that would
be
something but i i i would also agree
with amy my big fear with living is that
i've just never made a film like this
before eternally so
uh it depends on which version of me i
want people to meet the one that makes
films where people
cry at the end because it's so without
hope or they hopefully cried then
because it's hopefully full of hope
i'm curious uh amy when did you realize
that acting was something you really
wanted to pursue and oliver when did you
realize you wanted to you know tell
stories wow well i always i was i was i
loved writing when i was younger and i
wrote myself plays and things like that
and wrote plays from my friends and
got them all to act in it which they
hated but you know they did it anyway
but um
it then i was very very shy like really
shy really did very quiet child and then
i think when i yeah found
drama club
and stuff you know i always kind of did
funny sketches and bits with my mum and
we played all different characters and
stuff inside the house and then whenever
i get out i'd then be silent
um and then i kind of like didn't really
have any friends when i went to
secondary school and
it was
through you know
drama and
like i remember just one day we were
playing freeze tag you know where you
freeze and then you go in and you
improvise and i see
and i have been so shy and quiet at
school and my teacher just looked at me
because i actually loved her so much and
we had a real connection and she was
like you know get up cause she knew that
i liked doing all like my funny
characters but and i just i just went
for it i just stood up and i i went
freeze and everyone's like who is that
because i didn't speak and i went up and
i just started playing a funny like
father christmas i was playing santa
claus but like making him proper like
bloke and um
and then for and then i made loads of
friends and i connected with people and
i was like maybe and then it just stuck
so it was really it was really a tool to
make friends
actually
i uh my parents were huge influence um
when i was a kid uh
it was during apartheid and you know
things were banned and
uh it was just a sort of strange time to
to to to try and see culture and these
films and my parents love cinema um
my father very bizarrely when i was
probably too young took me to see a film
called the bear um the jean drug jane
film
and you know as you know it's a live
action film
about two days with no dialogue and it's
very french and we were watching it in a
movie house in a hotel and
there was just something about that that
stuck i just thought that's that's like
magic or something there's a wizardry to
that where i can watch something and
it's so moving um i i sort of wanted to
like the wizard of oz i wanted to be
behind all of that
for people uh because no one will have
seen living yet uh or almost no one
who's gonna read or watch this interview
um who wants to bite the bullet and and
describe the film
[Laughter]
well i mean beyond the fact that it's um
inspired and based on an existing film
by the extraordinary akira kurosawa
and also the reimagining
through the lens of
kazu ishiguro
this is a story about death affirming
life it's about a civil servant in the
50s in england
who realizes that he doesn't have much
time left
and he's somehow struck by a crisis he
he comes to he comes to sense
instantly almost on the day
that
that there's something left unsaid in
the narrative of his life and it sort of
it sort of unfolds and unpacks into like
a crisis of
have i really lived at all um
and our film is the journey
of those remaining that remaining time
and
um amy plays
the light in the darkness of of that
journey
that's a very good i think you've done
that before i'm going to say
actually i have it
now yeah
that was really good that was very very
good um so i guess oliver i'm going to
ask you the most important question uh
now which is uh i heard that bill and
amy laughed a lot during takes and in
between takes how did you corral them
did they um
i mean i don't i didn't feel like i had
maybe i'm wrong about that
i didn't have to corral them i mean i
think like you know we uh our very first
week of shooting this film
more or less
was as in in the office this office
setup that we had
and that was really nice because we had
you know six or seven actors sitting
around a table for a good five or six
days and they got to know each other and
they got to do in a way we kind of did
various stages of the story um
and i think that was fun for everyone
because i think that
you can i mean we'll also tell you like
you know everyone got to know everyone
and
personal relationships developers but i
didn't mind honestly in mind that the
fact that you know and i i mean i
actually don't know as much as amy does
but i know there were lots of dirty
things on paper that were written
between them
yeah there was lots of kind of we were
we would try and seem more well behaved
i think when when oliver was present but
we were sending kind of secret notes and
stuff on the pieces of paper at the uh
in the office and we were having fun but
i think it was so
essential as well i think especially
with like with bill and i like we had to
have that they margaret and mrs williams
really have that connection like there's
just it's kind of unexpected but they
see something in each other that they
just really like about each other and um
i think that we had that in real life as
well and there were lots of i just
couldn't stop smiling like i was always
trying to make myself you know i was
like always kind of holding back a smile
because i just wanted to grin every time
i was with bill which i think
was probably
right and good you know apart from the
sad bits of course it would be weird if
i was smiling through those but um
yeah we did have a lot of fun we had a
lot of fun
i remember actually on that when we were
doing that office that week of office
there was one day where bull actually
said to me like i don't like because he
felt like he was being taken away
whenever he wasn't needed he was being
taken to his to his trailer of sorts and
it was one day he very sheepishly asked
me he's like could i stay because he
felt like everyone else was having so
much fun i was like of course you can
stay you can just hang out with me once
and that was a good sign i like the fact
that you didn't feel like want to be
like get me away from these people he
really wanted to hang out so
i think it was a good thing it was a
good thing that you know generally
the environment was kind of yeah it was
it was fun
yeah
the film opens with this vintage footage
of london and i loved it um uh how did
the decision get made to start with that
vintage footage
um i was up in the middle of the night
on youtube googling vintage london
i knew that i wanted to do a title
sequence i was originally gonna do
something else i was gonna do graphics
and then
i literally went on a deep dive on
youtube just looking for footage i knew
that i wanted something and there's
something quite extraordinary about that
footage
which is that when you watch that
footage and now that we have it in the
form
the costume of everyone who's in that
footage
is exactly what our costume designer did
i remember when i showed it to sandy
powell for the first time
the movie started and she was like oh
you've used archive it's going to like
show me up and i said you're like
absolutely not it actually shows how
extraordinary you are because the merge
of seeing those women on the streets in
the archives and then seeing how women
on the streets in in our in our um
beginning of the film as well
it's uncanny i mean it's i think in fact
that archive match is a testament to the
extraordinary work of sandy paul
yeah sandy's kind of talented she's okay
yeah she's pretty pretty good
she she'll land on her feet um
she's gonna she's gonna look again
she'll look good exactly
i really loved the script for this and i
think it does such a great job at
capturing so much and for both of you
i'm just curious if you could talk about
your reaction when you first read it and
the emotions that sort of hit you
yeah well i really needed to read it
when i read it
i was feeling quite
down in the dumps and um yeah and when
it came through and it just like seemed
to be so cosmic because
i read it and it was exactly just what i
needed to reconnect with which is just
you know
like seeing the kind of greatness of the
small things and and just
really
being
present and appreciating the people that
are around you and yeah i was really
really moved by it and it i just yeah i
i thought it was so rare because you
don't get you know you get might get
sent quite a lot of stuff through but it
is rare to actually get something that
you genuinely like fall in love with
it's not it doesn't happen that much
and so
yeah i just remember reading it and and
thinking
that it was kind of like sent at that
exact moment you know and
so yeah
that was how i mean when i first read it
um i was sort of i had like a panic
attack about it because it's a very hard
it's a very hard soul but it's quite a
it's quite a it's quite a dangerous ask
to a director going hey would you like
to tackle something that's based on a
original film that is much loved by the
whole world
and that is 70 years old
and more importantly that the
reimagining is being written by somebody
who the world also loves
um
there's something about all of that
there's just sort of like let me just
pour myself a glass of wine
and
i
i remember that it took me a very long
time which this is like
kazushiguru is the most wonderful man um
he's this otherworldly person and
what was very hard for me in the
beginning was that i had i didn't know
how to navigate
giving notes i didn't know how to
navigate like developing this film with
him
because i read something and i had ideas
and i wanted to change things and i
wanted to get my fingers into it as a
director but there was always this thing
of going can i really i mean how dare i
do this and he sort of just
said to me one day you need to tell me
what you want you need to like you need
to you need to be the director and i and
i just love that i love that
that that he's he's he's such a such a
collaborator um and then he couldn't
stop me because then i was just like
going nuts uh and we spent a lot of time
together and
you know the the script was just a
journey between him and i and i loved i
love that we got to do that
uh for for both of you i love learning
like the random behind the scenes facts
or things that might surprise people so
for soon to be fans of this film
what do you think would surprise people
to learn about the making of living i
mean i think one of the things that i
don't know if people will know but we
all know is that we actually shop living
in county hall
we shot it in the place that it set and
we did we didn't just shoot an exterior
here and there we literally lived there
it was ours and i think that's a
extraordinary
you know i don't that never happens you
know if you have a form set in the
coliseum you don't get to shoot in the
coliseum
and we did
there was a great day where we were on i
can't remember which street we were on
but you know like quite a busy street in
london
and um
bill managed to find a table
he
sourced a table
and a vars with flowers in it and some
italian uh restaurant brought lunch and
we had
we were sat on a table in the in like
the middle of the street in london
having lunch together
that was pretty special
and just yeah and on this kind of like
people managed to just kind of find this
table this tablecloth this vars and then
we had this great food and it was just
that was really
brilliant and amazing
on that note i need to stop with you
guys uh but i really yeah it's fine it
will you know it's okay i but i really
mean it sincerely i really thought you
guys did a great job with this i don't
say that with every interview that i do
this is this is really this movie really
meant a lot to me um and i'm just going
to say congrats i hope you guys have a
fantastic afternoon and oliver i hope
you're making another movie again soon
thank you very much thank you so much